hey sherry Michael Scott returning well
I'm gonna wait till the end of the day
because the book said it's best to wait
until the end of the day I don't know
yet I will have to have a call back okay
sherry yeah if you were getting fired
how would you want to be told so that
you could still be friends with the
person firing you Jen what's the name as
soon as possible Michael thanks I'll
call her back
wish I get fire
sherry okay I'm sorry
yeah nope okay like where is my desk
that is weird
this is not funny this is totally
unprofessional okay well you're the one
who lost the desk didn't lose my desk
okay calm down
where was the last place you saw okay
who moved my desk I think you should
retrace your steps okay I am going to
tell Michael and this entire office will
be punished colder warmer a little
warmer Hey warmer warmer warmer warmer
warmer cold cold cold back up
dwight shrute hi Dwight um what sort of
discounts are we giving on the gym I've
given you this information like 20 times
by the rain is now 978 so it's a
discount 7 ok thank you
gotta get back to work wash your hands
Kevin you should get one of these no
thank you
do you even know what this is it is a
fitness orb and it has completely
changed my life
forget everything you thought you knew
about ab workouts done this ab workout
is specifically designed to strengthen
your core numerous health benefits
strengthens your back better performance
in sports more enjoyable sex you're not
having sex
plus improved your reflexes now what I
caught that okay you know what
how much is that that's only 25 bucks
Wow
Jim somebody this is not funny why is my
stuff in here wow it's weird
ooh daughter birthday boy that's pretty
good yeah well I'm not paying for my own
stuff okay I know you did this because
you're friends with the ending machine
guy Oh Steve yeah oh no no no no that's
my pencil cup oh I don't think so I just
bought it I think so and you're gonna
hand it over to me I love these okay
Oh notice j1 I enjoy having breakfast in
bed I like waking up to the smell of
bacon sue me and since I don't have a
butler I have to do it myself so most
nights before I go to bed I will lay six
strips of bacon out on my George Foreman
grill then I go to sleep when I wake up
I plug in the grill I go back to sleep
again then I wake up to the smell of
crackling bacon it is delicious it's
good for me it's a perfect way to start
the day today I got up I stepped onto
the grill and I clamped down on my foot
that's it I don't see what's so hard to
believe about that Jim's been looking at
me kind of a lot all week I would be
creeped out by it but it's nothing
compared to the way Michael looks at me
you don't know what they are going to
set think we have to think it through
because if they say no can we not know
yes we have to you know why because I
don't like to be cooped up in that
office in that box all day long
husband because I need to think okay Jim
Oh Kevin oh nice catch
mm-hmm intercept dad's right here though
give it to me Phil it's gonna be ball
okay give me the ball
Kim you guys create give me the ball
right leg Oh give it to Brian you are a
Ryan right yeah Pam calling cards are
the wave of the future these things sell
themselves who uses calling cards anyway
you know what that's a nice attitude
Ryan I'm just helping you invest in your
future my friend it sounds like a
get-rich-quick scheme yes thank you you
will get rich quick we all will can you
lose a lot of money on that other
investment that one from the email you
know what Toby when the son of the
deposed King of Nigeria emails you
directly asking for help you helped his
father ran the freaking country okay all
right so raise your hand if you want to
get rich all right No
how is this not a pyramid scheme all
right let me explain again phil has
recruited me and another guy now we are
getting three people each the more
people to get involved the more people
who are investing the more money we're
all gonna make it's not a pyramid scheme
it is a it's not even a scheme per se
it's
I have to go make a call let's go over
some of these symptoms of marijuana use
shall we you tell me who this sounds
like slow-moving inattentive dull
constantly snacking shows a lack of
motivation I like the people I work with
generally with four exceptions but
someone committed a crime and I did not
become a Lackawanna County volunteer
sheriff's deputy to make friends and by
the way I haven't excuse me how long is
the wait for a table for two I would
never ever serve you not in a million
billion years it's a nice tux I know and
belonged to my grandfather he was buried
in it so family heirloom
so what's the deal we got to pay for our
own drinks that's my come on it'll be
fun and besides I'm a roulette expert
impossible roulette is not a game of
skill it is a game of chance I could
always kind of win it or what oh really
mm-hmm
yeah how would you do that my control
you can't be serious hey serious ever
since I was a little kid like eight or
nine I could sort of control things with
my mind I don't believe you would
continue it was just little things you
know like I could make something shake
or I could make a marble fall off the
counter you know just little things
that's ridiculous you know what uh why
don't you move that cup rack excuse me
everyone attention in the office please
Jim is about to prove his telekinetic
powers and he needs absolute silence go
ahead okay I'll try
you